check out this story the war zone this
man owns the world's most advanced
private air force after buying 46 f-18
Hornets we talked to the owner of Air
USA about probably the most incredible
private aircraft purchase of all time
and the future of his adversary of his
adversary business adversary business
look at this I can't believe this is
real I got to be honest is this guy like
super rich or something is that a
kangaroo on the side there it is that's
the girl look right behind his head I
think that is totally a kangaroo and you
can see here you got that tiger check
this out first I want to show you some
pictures let me let me actually increase
the let me zoom in on this that's his
new Air Force team Wow
dude I mean this this is the reason I
wanted to be in the Air Force I mean my
uncle was in the Air Force also but I
wanted to fly those planes but I'm
colorblind and I have glasses so nope
not a lot of fly planes so that that you
know have you ever seen little miss
sunshine yeah a long time ago so the Sun
is talking about flying jets and the
grand dad is like oh does he know that
he you know he's colorblind so he can't
and the kid like freaks out and he's
just like screaming in the sky yeah that
was me I mean I wasn't screaming about
it but I I definitely was bummed cuz
when I was 8 year old me I'm like one of
the first games I ever had was this it
was afterburner it was a little tiny
cockpit like you you know you had the
little thing and you'd accelerate the
plane and all it was was just a little
arcade like moved to the left or the
right to avoid stuff or shoot a man I
loved it and I just wanted to be a
fighter pilot and I found out I couldn't
got to have perfect evasion bum so I'm a
little jealous this guy's got 46 planes
well I guess if you have to choose if
you privately owned a fighter you so
that's what I need to do yeah and they
get clearance to fly it I guess or just
befriend this this dude yeah we've got a
couple extras here's what they say for
the for the last 30 years Don kerlun has
been flying for the airlines working on
real estate deals
setting up the world's biggest skydiving
meets and building a private Air Force
the likes of which even he has a hard
time believing as possible just last
month the war zone was among the first
report that his company would be
purchasing
multiple squadrons worth of surplus
Royal Australian Air Force Wow raf f-18
Hornets to be used in the contractor
adversary air support role here in the
United States not only do we have all
the details on that purchase which is
even more impressive than it initially
seemed but we talked at length with the
entrepreneur owner of air USA located in
Quincy Illinois Wow know about his
company's past and what is turning into
and what is turning into a remarkable if
not downright historic future so is this
like private air security it sounds like
it all right what's security for his
company well I think this is right it
sounds like it's run by his company well
yeah so I don't want to read through the
basic history of his company not to be
disrespectful to his company I want to
hear about what he's gonna be doing with
these things
yes check this out enter the most
spectacular private aircraft purchase of
all time Air USA's acquisition of all of
the Royal Australian Air Forces
remaining fa-18 a B Hornets Canada had
bought 25 prior to this deal going
through the Jets air air USA is slated
to receive 46 in total of which 36 are
flying today will be replaced by the
f-35 fighter within the RAAF s ranks and
thus will be totally retired from
service by the end of 2021
damn how to take one man I want one much
- how much you think it costs for him to
buy do they mention that was the first
thing I bought in GTA 5 was the Hydra
the the plane that could harrier that
could just go off and fly but these
things can't do that right no no I don't
think so
so the they're talking about about
configurations and stuff all of Air
USA's secondhand hornets feature a and a
PG 73 radar the same one that is found
on the f-18 CD and and this is a lot of
jargon for me on the super hornets that
differ from the less capable anap g65
radar I have no idea what that is
yes I'm trying to figure out what the
cost of this one was gonna do with them
it right no how much did it cost
check us out the Jets also come with
their Northrop Grumman a naa q28
lightning
Vance targeting pods which are hugely
capable in the air-to-ground targeting
and non-traditional reconnaissance realm
as well as for positively identifying
aircraft visually at long ranges you can
read all about this function and its
value in this past piece of ours in
addition the Hornets come with 68 joint
helmet mounting queueing systems which
offers helmet-mounted display capability
and drastically increases a pilot's
situational awareness and high off bore
sight targeting for close range
air-to-air missiles this will make it
easier for these aggressor jets to
simulate foreign capabilities of a
similar nature but what are they going
to do like what does he do with these
someone someone tagged me and they said
that they're using them to be the
adversaries in training air force so
they're not facing each other they're
facing another cycle group Wow I don't
know if that's true but I do appreciate
you guys all tagging me in randomly it's
pretty good what's for training some
other they learn they learn to dogfight
with each other
Wow pretty pretty cool so there that's
not a part of the Air Force so this is
this is the team I need to get on yeah
well they let you fly even we have
similar you know similar conditioning no
I have no idea I'm not sure I wonder
what the price is what is this 70
million dollars a piece
what yep someone someone tagged me 33
million per plane oh this says a unit
cost the 2017 fly away cost was seventy
point five
where is that is that per jet yeah
seventy million is that brand new though
yeah it must be but these are used
weren't they so 33 million makes sense
that does make sense okay times so so so
team four billion dollars did he spend a
billion dollars that's crazy
well I may do my math wrong that's a
billion dollars right I don't know let
me see 33 times 46
it's like 46 yeah it was 18 for some
reason he bought he bought 46 yeah
1.5 billion 1.5 billion
yeah I gotta become a billionaire yes so
that I can buy no no you don't need you
don't need 40 of them you need like one
dad - okay you're right I need to get
them you need your summertime jet and
the the wintertime jet no gosh sometimes
you want to put the top down you know
here they say it says JT ACS needs to
get time on the mic with real aircraft
overhead in both day and nighttime
conditions to get accustomed to
organizing the three-dimensional
airspace overhead in relationship to the
battlespace on the ground and
effectively safely and efficiently call
in airstrikes and enemy targets this is
an incredibly complex and high-stakes
job but using high-performance fighters
in the Pentagon's inventory that cost at
least twenty thousand dollars an hour to
train with is horribly cost ineffective
as such being able to provide far less
expensive assets via that can contra the
contractor marketplace for some of this
training has become a major priority yep
so it's training ooh did you mean to
tell me this guy has got a lucrative
business and all these fighter jets when
there's when the zombie apocalypse
happens this guy's got an got air
superiority yeah cool isn't like like
the American war doctrine like based on
air superiority or something like that's
like a big part of what we do that's
true yeah I hope so
yeah props to the chat for hitting me up
with the appropriate information
appreciate you guys what is this he's
also got helicopters oh who is this guy
I was like wow this guy wow man so he
also has cessna's apparently which have
reciprocating turbocharged io 360
engines found in normal light planes
extremely efficient our criminal
efficient compared to their turbine
powered competitors and feature video
downlink encrypted communications and
night-vision goggle compatible cockpits
among other modifications they are also
certified under the FAA FAA standard
category not the experimental category
even with all their modifications which
is a multitude of benefits check this
out you know it's this remember early I
was talking about people buying houses
in Maine yeah I'm like what who are
these people got 1.5 billion dollars to
buy all these but but how does he have
all that money think he's got a nice
place in Maine
while he lives in Illinois buddy's got a
really nice place in Illinois yeah true
but how do you secure I mean I think
it's fair to say maybe he didn't
personally buy them
maybe he secured a big loan and said we
got a government contract guarantee over
30 years or something like that and so
he got people to finance it yeah I'd
imagine that would make sense and now he
gets a stand in front of them and talked
to you know about how he is the one who
has all of these and I'm sure he is very
happy about it I'm glad he's been able
to they have a bunch of other stuff
apparently check this out he's got tons
of planes like not just the ones he just
recently bought yeah we're good over so
they do skydiving and stuff there's a
real interesting article because it
basically goes into literally everything
but I got I got to confess I don't know
enough about the jargon yeah other than
how big I'm curious how big this Air
Force is compared to the other others in
the world unit I heard this could be not
true maybe it maybe it's true there's a
thing that you know it's not really a
joke it's kind of like a point do you
know who has the biggest air force in
the world
I don't do you know what the biggest air
force in the world is I I don't the
United States Air Force okay you're the
second-biggest Air Force in the world is
I don't the United Sates Navy I did hear
that I've heard that before I don't know
if it's true it's not really surprising
though I mean totally so like the naval
vessels the aircraft carriers that's not
that's not the Air Force that's not Navy
what's a Navy yeah I mean I don't know
I'm assuming I always just assumed it
was kind of like a joint effort you know
like they cuz I think the Air Force was
was handling out of space stuff too now
the space force does it right but they
handle a lot of other stuff that the
Navy wouldn't so I actually know this
this original space stuff would be from
a little bit of everyone right every
every different aspect of the army had a
little piece of it and it made a mess of
it and that's why space force actually
does make some sense dude whatever this
guy is doing he did it right yeah I need
to figure that out yeah he's alright
dude so I can I can have a photo of like
look at how happy is happy dude he's
like yeah check out my jet you know what
you know it's funny I know it's really
really funny I think it was I think it
was Eric's Wawa I'm not sure a Democrat
who made a point about second the Second
Amendment okay and he's had something a
lot
maybe it wasn't him I may be wrong but
he said something about buying a tank
and like he's like are you gonna go buy
a tank and you know of course not there
are limits
you actually could buy a tank people I
want to I know Hank is but I actually
looked it up and fact-check you can buy
a tank that's dealt with artillery and
everything you're you're totally with
artillery yeah I'm pretty and maybe I'm
pretty sure actually yeah and there was
a story about apparently somebody bought
a tank and was out firing a full auto 50
Cal into a lake and someone called the
cops and the cops were like I don't know
what we do about that what are we
supposed to do
excuse me sir excuses please know that
excuse me sir excuse me yeah right but
uh apparently he was logged do it he was
like the guy I don't know the full story
you can look it up maybe I'm wrong
my general memory of it is that like he
owned the lake it was his property he
was firing into it oh so like yeah I
want to tank you own the guns your
property you can do it you want yeah I
read a funny article about some guy that
a tank and he parked it in his front
yard and like the homeowners association
started complaining and he was like I
don't care what you have to say go ahead
and move it you don't like it go ahead
and try and move it and they're just
like but it's but I think it's funny
like the reason I bring it up is you
want to talk about the right to bear
arms one of the things they always say
is like you you you you think you're
gonna be able to fend off the government
in a revolution cuz it's like you know
some conservatives will say the right to
bear arms stop a tyrannical government
yeah then the left will say the
government has nukes you know what are
you gonna do well this guy just bought
some are from the Royal Australian Air
Force some some Hornets yeah so you know
that he has the right to bear these arms
you know like probably it probably would
been more if Canada didn't snag those 25
jets so let me just say for those that
would question whether or not you have
the right to bear arms in this country
while there are certainly strange laws
and infringement yeah if anyone ever
says to you what what are you gonna do
against you as government shown this guy
like well this guy bought a bunch of
fighter jets
he's working with the government I was
just saying he's probably contracted to
like they might have helped him pay for
this it's true because if it's that much
cheaper for them to use him as their
practice pilots you know that he buys
these jets yeah I'm just saying like
clearly the dude has the right to bear
arms even fighter jets yeah so you know
exactly I wonder what the legal
loopholes were you know the other thing
is - hmm but there's no law in the books
saying you can't do it I I didn't know
that I'd wake up today with finding a
new goal in life to buy some fighter
just have my own fighter jet hi I had no
idea well when you hit 33 million yeah
you can make you can get your first
that's the crazy thing to me I'm like
how do you even get to 33 million let
alone 1.5 billion yeah well that's why I
think it was it wasn't just him it was
probably financing and stuff like that
he had a company tax something or yeah
yeah
a lot of things like that yeah weird
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
if you want to catch the full show tune
in to this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you